This is Sarah. Sarah is a
sales professional and a
Tango Me user.
When she wants to meet with clients,
she uses Tango Me because it
eliminates all scheduling conflicts,
time zone differences, and
the back-and-forth emails associated with
finding times that work
for everyone. Here's how it
works: Jean is Sarah's client.
Sarah sends him an email with
details of an upcoming project.
He wants to schedule a
phone call to discuss it, so he
clicks on the Tango Me link
in Sarah's email signature.
He arrives at her Tango Me page where he can
see her availability. He
clicks to reschedule,
adds details, selects a few times,
and sends it all without having
to register.
Sarah receives the email invitation.
She sees the times Jean suggested
overlaid on her calendar, chooses a
time that works for her, and clicks "
booking."
The appointment is automatically
added to Sarah's calendar, and Jean
receives an email confirmation
to add it to his. It's also  It's that
simple:
Sarah's Tangonis page only displays
the times she has chosen to mark
as available. She has indicated that she is
available mornings and afternoons
from Monday to Thursday each week. She
has also synchronized Tango Me with
her calendar so that new
events are automatically added, and
she won't have any appointment conflicts.
Sarah has also chosen to display
a photo of her
contact information and a link to her
personal blog on her Tango Me page. She also shares the link
to her page everywhere she logs in:
she adds it to her email signature,
sends it to her clients via Skype,
tweets it (quite a following!), displays it on her
LinkedIn profile, and includes it on her
business card.
Soon everyone will be using Tango, which will make scheduling
appointments even easier. For this,
she can search for colleagues
in the Tango Me directory and add them
to her list of contacts.
She can organize
group meetings by selecting contacts or
adding names to a Tango
Me address to see
everyone's availability, overlapping them with each other.
She can invite...  People who
don't use Tango for meetings,
using only their email addresses, don't
need to register to
respond.
She can also schedule
meetings from her iPhone or Blackberry
and respond to invitations from
any smartphone. That's how
Tango makes
creating meetings quick and easy
for Sarah. So, are you ready to
wait?